[Aplausos]
qué
mi nombre es felipe jiménez y estar acá
es muy tranquilo porque el 90% de mi
tiempo estoy perdido
literalmente una época y mediante no
sabía si quería ser metalero búnker o
rapero lo haya náter o payaso y si no
estoy perdida estoy buscando algo
literalmente siempre se me pierden las
llaves siempre se me pierde el celular
la billetera para mí era muy importante
venir a hablar de esto porque
porque siento que cuando estamos
perdidos creemos que es algo malo y es
sinónimo de fracaso e incluso es causal
de depresión
y yo creo que una de las razones por las
cuales esto sucede es porque perderse es
muy similar la palabra perder y perder
significa no ganar pero para mí perderse
es abrir oportunidades
me repito un poquito de nuestro famoso
maturana quien hablaba que perder es
ganar un poco yo no llego a perderse es
ganar de a pocos o ganarse de a pocos
desde chiquitos aprendemos con frases
como estamos perdidos para decir que
estamos fregados o nos fuimos en
pérdidas para decir que no hay plata
incluso la persona que es vaga le
decimos que está perdiendo el tiempo
pero cosa que más nos llega al fondo es
que nos enseñamos a siempre mantener la
mirada en la meta final contra él y no
perdernos en el camino le tenemos miedo
a perdernos en el camino hacemos
preguntas como que quiere ser cuando
seas grande
qué quieres estudiar cuál es tu plan de
vida cómo te ves en 5 años o en 10 pero
casi nadie nos pregunta cómo nos vemos
ahora en este momento
muchas veces por estar pendientes de ese
futuro ni siquiera miramos lo que
estamos viviendo en el presente y eso
hace que pasemos por encima de lo que
sea incluso de quien sea para conseguir
esas metas
yo hago el ejemplo de un corredor
tenemos un corredor imaginario al final
de ese corredor está esa meta eso que
queremos hacer eso que queremos llegar
súper claro si tenemos además la fortuna
de saber exactamente qué es lo que
queremos y si se para un montón de
personas en la mitad vamos a pasar
derecho porque vamos a ir por nuestras
metas y ni siquiera nos vamos a mirar a
los ojos ni siquiera saber si les
estamos haciendo daño cuando pasamos por
encima de ellos y para mí la vía es un
poco más así donde muchas puertas pero
sí sé exactamente en cuál puerta está
exactamente lo que estoy buscando
voy a ir derecho esa puerta y no voy a
tener ni siquiera la la intención de
mirar a otras puertas pero para mí la
verdad es que la vida se ve un poquito
más así
donde hay un montón de puertas donde no
sé en cuál está lo que estoy buscando
muchas veces ni siquiera que sé que lo
que estoy buscando es una oportunidad
gigante porque me toca mirar en todas
porque voy a mirar en la primera y
pronto algo que no me gustaba mira en la
segunda de protego que me gusta no tanto
mucho y me quedé ahí incluso el mismo
puede haber un montón de otras puertas
que pueda ir abriendo yo soy fiel
creciente que nos podemos empoderar de
estar perdidos y que podemos sacar un
mayor provecho entonces quiero hacer la
pregunta a los que estamos acá si estar
perdido significa no saber si se está en
el camino correcto quiénes de los que
estamos acá nos sentimos perdidos en en
alguna parte de nuestras vidas
porque no estoy solo no soy el único que
está perdido el 90% del tiempo y es muy
bonito y les agradezco que levantan la
mano porque es normal es humano estar
perdido es maravilloso es más yo tengo
la teoría de que nos gusta estar
perdidos recordemos cuando éramos
chiquitos y jugábamos a las escondidas
oa la gallina ciega oa esconder una
pelota y era una delicia estar buscando
nos divertíamos y cuando lo encontramos
era un placer gigante pero más nos
demoramos en encontrar lo que estar
diciendo vuelvo a esconder bueno vuelven
a esconder porque hay algo en esa
búsqueda hay algo ahí que nos llama la
atención y eso es obviamente el placer
de encontrar claro que estamos hablando
de perderse para siempre y nunca buscar
una salida no me imagino el que está
perdido en una montaña durante tres
meses y que pasean y le digan ayuda
persona no no es que el otro oyente
dijeron que estar perdido era una
delicia eso no voy a pasar que en ese
término que es balance y el término alas
es un término que yo adoro porque el
término a los otros términos que creemos
que está perdido y hablamos todo el
tiempo de que tenemos que encontrar un
balance pero yo aquí traigo una muy mala
noticia no por ser pesimista
sino porque yo no creo que encontremos
un balance yo creo que el balance es un
estado es un estado en constante
movimiento tenemos por ejemplo una
pelota con una tabla encima si yo me
paro sobre esa tabla obviamente va a
tener que empujar hacia un lado y hacia
el otro para mantenerme en ese balance y
si es pincho para para allá tengo que
hacer la misma presión hacia el otro
lado para volverme a balancear pero cada
que respire cada que me canse un lado me
voy a mover y va a tener que equilibrar
ese movimiento la única forma para
encontrar un balance perfecto un punto
neutro es siendo un objeto inmóvil y
para hacer un objeto inmóvil tendría que
no estar vivo o que la tabla estuviera
en el piso y sería luego más aburrido el
planeta
como hago yo para buscar ese balance la
pregunta que me llena todo el tiempo y
la pregunta porque justo la escuchábamos
ahorita
porque voy a moverme hacia allá porque
hoy en poder hacia allá porque estoy
cansado de la otra pierna porque quiero
ver hasta dónde puedo llegar aún conoce
que las consecuencias que va a tener que
empujar de nuevo tenemos en cuenta que
el balance es personal el balance lo
escoge de cada persona pero el balance y
la pregunta porque nos llena de
propósitos una persona que siempre se
pregunta el que se pregunta por sus
logros y quien solo habla de sus logros
es un egocéntrico
por una persona que todo el tiempo
pregunta por qué
se pregunta sus propósitos y quien sólo
habla de sus propósitos es un visionario
yo por ejemplo llevo tres años en una
empresa que no tenemos ni idea qué
hacemos
pero todos estamos convencidos de por
qué lo hacemos todos sabemos porque
estamos en esta empresa
y cuando sabemos por qué buscamos algo y
no que buscamos pedimos ayuda y cuando
pedimos ayuda nos relacionamos nos
conectamos escuchamos a otras personas y
cuando escuchamos escuchamos tan
profundamente que no tenemos miedo de
reinventarnos no se pueden amos tanto
que no nos rendimos somos científicos
buscamos aquí y probamos aquí erramos
vuelvo a buscar por aquí vuelve miro me
volver al mismo sitio porque de pronto
apareció mágicamente ha ido de pronto no
lo había antes cuando haya mirado
volvemos a ser niños y buscamos buscamos
nuevas salidas y buscamos nuevas rutas y
nuevos retos
y queremos conocer pero más importante
que querer conocer necesitamos conocer
porque estamos perdidos estamos con el
otro y estamos para el otro
entonces si es tan rico esto estar
perdido como se llega a estar perdida
no sé si todos están o conocen la ruta
del héroe de la dramaturgia de la
narrativa del héroe básicamente todo
héroe en cualquier novela pasa por el
mismo proceso donde tiene una intención
conoce a alguien le pide ayuda a éste le
brinda su ayuda a toma una decisión de
lanzarse prueba y falla prueba y falla
hasta que al final llega una crisis no
necesario caer en la crisis del euro
donde nos morimos donde casi recibimos
pero ahí es donde más nos sentimos
perdidos porque en esa crisis algo muy
sencillo como ya no sé qué vestido
ponerme allá me probé 17 vestidos para
el matrimonio sólo me quedan dos y los
dos cumplí con todas mis expectativas en
ese momento no tengo nada que perder
ya perdí todo lo demás no importa la
crisis no importa lo perdido que esté si
ya llegué a la crisis ya perdí todo lo
demás y cuando no tengo nada que perder
tengo todo por ganar y en ese momento
perdemos lo único que nos queda perdemos
el control cuando perdemos en control
empezamos a valorar lo que tenemos o lo
que teníamos si ya no perdimos y nos
quedan opciones me rindo
me vuelvo por donde viene estoy perdido
y no quiero seguir o voy
y cuando hoy vuelvo a ese corredor lleno
de puertas y como no sé ni siquiera que
estoy buscando ahora esas puertas y lo
bonito de ese momento es que encontramos
algo antes no teníamos nada no teníamos
nada que perder en ese momento
encontramos algo algo y ese algo lo
valoramos más que cualquier cosa en el
mundo porque lo que tenemos antes de
comenzar esta charla estaba muy dudoso
en la historia en mi vida les podía
contar en donde yo estuviera perdido
incluso estaba perdido buscando qué
historia me decía contar
entonces decidí que no decía contar una
historia si les iba a contar dos dice
les voy a contar este al tiempo una de
la historia porque hago lo que hago y la
otra la historia es que tuve la
oportunidad de ir al mundial en la
primera me encontraba en la cumbre de mi
carrera estaba trabajando en londres en
uno de los estudios que para mí era más
importantes y tal vez había encontrado
lo que había estaba buscando toda mi
vida era un músico trabajando en
inglaterra en un estudio de grabación
pero en esos momentos decidieron que mi
vida
estudiante tenía que volver a colombia y
yo lógicamente me acerqué a los del
estudio les expliqué mi situación
pedimos una charla muy bonita donde les
decía que yo sabía que ellos valorar mi
trabajo es valorado mucho de ellos y que
quería que me patrocinar mis ellos muy
amablemente inmediatamente me dijeron
que no y que estaba despedido pero
cuando me despidieron fue muy chévere
porque fue ese llamado ese llamado debe
decir algo tengo que hacer y salí y pedí
ayuda y pregunté me hablaron de una
residencia inglesa para la creación de
un modelo de negocio sostenible para el
reino unido que todavía hoy no tengo ni
idea qué significa pero decidí mandarme
porque tenía un propósito en el momento
de que yo porque me quiero quedar porque
quiero pelear contra esto porque me
tienen que echar por haber nacido en
otro país que les hice yo y empecé ahí
busqué y me encontré con un gran amigo
que me dijo yo voy con usted para las
que sean y nos montamos en la otra
historia de mi vida
cuando logré conocer un mundial por
razones de la vida alguna persona que
publicó en internet que tenía dos
boletos para un partido sobrando yo las
compren sin siquiera tener un tiquete y
la vía me llevó a que justamente en esa
época iba a estar cerca donde iba a
pasar el mundial pero yo no era mi mami
lehman a que antes de eso había comienza
había conocido una persona que ya
comenzaba a salir con ella y estaba esta
duda de será que si es el momento para
irnos juntos a un mundial o un viaje tan
largo dios mío dame señales unos días
antes de tener que irnos para el
aeropuerto teníamos que un tren
para acercarnos hacia allá y ella quien
también pierde todo todo el tiempo me
dijo que se le había perdido los
tiquetes del tren
y yo dije no importa yo acá voy a la
ropa la lavandería mimetiza que toda la
ropa metí en los bolsillos y aquí no
está me devolvió el hotel donde
estábamos y ellos ya se había subido a
la habitación a buscar allá pero cuando
subí ya la habían limpiado entonces dije
claro ya debe estar lógicamente entre
toda la basura del hotel buscando los
tiquetes me fui a la basura del hotel y
cuando llegué yo estaba a ella con un
montón de papeles higiénicos y no
higiénicos y por más rara que fuera la
escena decidí mandarme a la caneca y
una de esas bolsas y cuando llegue
al fondo de la bolsa lo que me encontré
no lo esperaba en el fondo esas bolsas
estaban las boletas del partido al que
íbamos a ir
y no teníamos ni idea que las habíamos
perdido y en ese momento nos abrazamos
lloramos nos reímos no les miento justo
en ese momento se abrió un ascensor y
salió una señora diciendo se perdieron
estos dos billetes de entre en ser ante
ustedes
hay que entender y entiendo la señal
entiendo la señal voy voy con ella y nos
montamos y dijimos bueno vamos a
este vuelo y vamos a ir juntos y vamos a
empoderar y nos dijeron ustedes tienen
que hacer una escala en un país donde
los van a detener 16 horas pero ya les
van a dar un hotel ustedes tranquilos no
se preocupen pasan llegamos a ese país
súper felices vamos a conocer un mundial
revisábamos acá dos minutos que las
bolitas si quieren con nosotros
obviamente pasó una persona pasa nada
otra pasión yo
y cuando pasó ellos nos dijeron la niña
no puede pasar
porque nunca nos dijeron por qué
pero si me dijeron que yo tenía un hotel
que podía ser las 16 horas para que ella
no podía ingresar ese país tenemos 16
horas para resolver e intentamos
intentamos pagar de una forma no nos
recibían en ese país no existía el
internet no teníamos forma de
comunicarnos pasaron 24 6 10 horas no
habíamos dormido no habíamos comido
de pronto mágicamente apareció un bueno
de australia anthony a un colombiano con
un celular que servía en ese país
logramos conectarnos a internet llamamos
a colombia tampoco nos pudieron ayudar y
sólo faltaba una hora y media para
tenerme que ir tenemos que tuvimos que
tomar esa decisión
me voy me quedo nos devolvemos por donde
veníamos qué hacemos
volviendo a mi primera historia
nos habíamos ganado esa residencia nos
presentaban desgranamos 2000 personas se
presentaron y nosotros vínculos
gloriosos ganadores pero de la nada
teníamos un carné que decía emprendedor
residente el sector cultural no teníamos
ni idea de nada eso pero nos mandamos y
es que vivimos escribimos una obra de
teatro preguntamos cómo estaba la
corregimos escribimos otra teníamos un
año para presentar una obra de teatro no
teníamos ni idea de que íbamos a
escribir pero probamos y programas de
programas cuando faltaban solamente tres
meses para el estreno me rompieron una
pierna me tuve que volver a colombia
operarme
estábamos todos en colombia presente por
primera vez el guión y la obra era un
desastre a nadie le gustó y por si fuera
poco las obras no sólo era un desastre
sino que en colombia estaban estrenando
al mismo tiempo una obra con exactamente
el mismo nombre exactamente el mismo
tema y el protagonista era exactamente
el mismo actor que yo quería
no teníamos nada y nos quedan dos meses
para presentar una obra de teatro nos
bajamos nos rendimos no tenemos nada que
perder ya lo perdimos todo en ese
momento alguien se para vídeo tan solo
nos queda hacer un esto perdamos el
control vamos allá nos paramos en la
tarima y contamos por qué porque no nos
gusta que nos echen de un país y así lo
hicimos y nos fuimos un mes antes con el
propósito de decir la obra de teatro se
trata de nosotros mismos y lo más
sorprendente es que en un solo mes se
sumaron un montón de personas que
querían hablar de lo mismo y la gente
sólo se estaba pegando nuestro propósito
a ese porque ya no estábamos perdidos en
ese momento sabíamos porque estábamos
buscando algo pero no teníamos ni idea
que lo que nos íbamos a encontrar el
resultado fue un gran aplauso de todo el
público al final
volviendo al aeropuerto después de la
despedida más titánica que ese plan
imaginar donde ya se quedó llorando en
el piso le decía te lo juro que no me
vas a perder y me fui al partido
obviamente una seguridad tener mi boleta
antes de pasar en 15 minutos sólo 15
minutos logré que lo que no habíamos
logrado 16 horas que fue conseguir un
tiquete para 24 horas después ya tiene
que tener esperar 24 horas más más el
otro vuelo
al otro día oa los dos días nos
encontramos al otro día ya llegó y sí
llegó y estuvimos en el mundial y
gustamos muchísimo y fuimos a ese
partido y cuando celebra selección
cantamos el himno nacional como si nadie
hubiera nunca ha visto la selección y en
tan sólo dos minutos la selección a
meter un gol y perdimos ese partido el
único partido al que vamos a ir
pero ella llegó y cuando perdimos ese
partido nos abrazamos lloramos nos
reímos agradecidos muchísimo porque
sabemos que nadie nadie somos muy
poquitas personas reales que aman
estadios entonces realmente la próxima
muy poquito las personas que pueden
estar ahí lo agradecemos muchísimo y nos
encontramos con un amor muy honesto más
social que nos íbamos a encontrar desde
antes
con estos viajes me quedo un sentimiento
de honestidad un sentimiento de diciendo
mi historia diciendo mis cosas puedo
llegar mucho más lejos puedo transformar
vidas y me quedé una idea es sinceridad
de ser yo mismo ya no me interesa ser
metalero rockero quiero todo lo hago una
misma banda pero me quedo sobre todo un
aire de confianza una confianza brutal
una confianza en los demás en cada
persona que me dio la mano cuando yo le
pedí ayuda y una confianza en mí mismo
yo los invito aquí a perderse el que
esté perdido no se juzgue tierra se
tranquilo aproveche agradezca estar
prendido y el que no está perdido busque
perderse cada vez soy más amante la
frase que dice que no hay camino sino
que el camino se hace al andar porque
entre más andamos más puerta se abre y
entre más puertas se abren más perdemos
la cabeza y más perdemos el control y
entre menos control tenemos más nos
perdemos en el tiempo y ahora se aseguró
que no hay nada más maravilloso no hay
nada más hermoso en esta vida que sea lo
que sea que nos vayamos a encontrar
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]